the penalties and we're just fine
gentlemen hey I'm Martin are you are you
doing sir so tell us a little bit about
ancestors left legacy right so ancestors
legacy is a real-time squad-based
squad-based realtime strategy nice
history inspired it takes place in
medieval Europe now and I'm walking off
medieval with a bottle of the time frame
okay that's perfect we get four
different nations a good playful Vikings
anglo-saxons German source labs
wonderful over here is the beginning of
my Vikings are our fine
and fulfilling the individual tasks come
up so that's the basics on a single
foreign campaign is going to be about
that's it in total it's going to have
about 40 hours of gameplay magic plus
there's the multiplayer of course which
is out on what now do real treat - do I
have to play with your bodies you can
play in the
well you can even go solo
yes this is an Lord addict exclusive
remember this is a huge halo wars RTS
guidances playing right nabob a better
so he is in heavenly peace in his soul
right there in that now if you in
comparison to again like a halo yours is
there anything that
it's coming to consoles we're releasing
for PC on May 22nd and but guys are also
working on Xbox one version including
the Xbox 1x which is actually running
their own so this is Xbox one Xbox one X
so we doing the whole thing
visually on par with the PC version
movies and cross-platform multiplayer is
still in the question as well might have
ended up working in Ajmer yes awesome
let me I'm sure that there are xbox one
exlusive a question what about we have a
baby for example a few who don't have 4k
TV
we will they have a performance more
definitely what you see right now is a
bill that's a couple weeks old again so
this has basically been optimized for
Xbox one the regular
so officially this is 4k but like the
visual fidelity otherwise discuss the
final version this still looks great
even this part a still some some tweaks
to be done in this fixes in tweeds to be
done involve some narrative questions
don't
you know what like I said it's that time
period that the I love podcast loves
what do we have like a essential base
though
of the nation's century campaigns so in
each of the can kind of major events
here it's the Vikings there also there's
also the power fights between pig-out
and some of it
although
[Music]
because of trying to be as historically
accurate as possible we used to say that
it's historically a good game of course
someone found a little so that
dismemberment hey it's hard but even the
guys that are into history that they're
like biking three night sweats and stuff
like that really happy with MOOCs and
all the details that are there in this
are to us
feature
I need the heavy can you press the left
joystick right now yeah
there's over 600 motion get some
animations or device only and it also
again always defense at these issues
rendering for sword slash change back
and what I like about is the incident
like there's an ultimate cinematic
they're rushing again this orbán one of
the gates yes
something that most Argos
right
Denny's between you fam it's really nice
our spell yeah this is an RTS y'all
where you have just like the small squad
of soldiers and he too knows sneak your
way through the enemy lines you
pretty close to release it's coming out
in May 22nd for CCS or so that bill this
is getting quotes and bunch of words
that the guys are finalizing all the
stuff when were finalizing the balancing
water chatted with the Billy so here you
can see is food and wood it's pretty
streamlined so all you need to do now
after you've kept read the read Ruth
your peasants and they go on my Kindle
resources automatically alright so you
still have to build your buildings you
still have to reach with your peasant
spot
it's more streamlined it's really
focused on
yes it's one by one you can you can
assign a number to a group of units by
it's like the poured in for directions
on the d-pad so when it comes to
multiplayer
multiplayers the boat
yes we had an open beta multiplayer from
January till the end of March we had
over 7,000 wires in there so a lot of
balancing has been done during that
period and so I'm quite confident that
it's pretty balanced already did you
have a good transition from keyboard a
mouse to Jeanette roller how does that
process work is it is it complicated
well this has actually been developed
for the controller right from the start
so it's not like it's been developed for
foreign policy they made it more
accessible yes so I think for me I hate
the controller but nice pretty well and
also on PC you can play mode if you
choose between the two he basically
transit from one to another for that so
if you see this it's like the
transported to place if you're sorry I'm
just going to break you up for two
seconds and you press something under
the controller it just turns into the
controller mode and then when you press
[Music]
quality so was it a bottle
Oh
join it again - policeman sees in the
I'm glad you like your IQ very happy
about this game of life so very much so
and again it's PC first @s DC on May
22nd 22nd and xbox early next year
sounds good we'll be looking out for